popular men's cosmetic products or
raising concerns this morning over a
potentially harmful ingredient led
acetate can be found in Grecian formula
and youth hair hair dye products but in
the United States consumer groups filed
a petition to the FDA to crack down on
the lead compound which they say is a
known neurotoxin Anna Werner shows us
the possible side effects of using these
dyes and a good morning well good
morning for nearly a decade Europe and
Canada have banned the sale of these
same products because they contain lead
acetate and those manufacturers offer
consumers in those countries a lead free
alternative so then why are American
consumers still able to purchase these
products if the petition is successful
that may change not that much on their
richard gandalf didn't like going gray
so for the past 20 years the 73 year-old
retired civil servant has been using a
cream that turns his grey hair dark and
take it here put it here that's it I'm
done he uses a product called youth hair
it was integration formula they soon be
call me a gray haired bald wear Grecian
formula is another familiar from those
1980s TV commercials I think the gray is
going slowly gradually and no one's
noticing something the ads don't mention
however is that both of those products
contain an ingredient which can be
harmful especially to children lead
acetate a lead compound which the CDC
lists as a possible carcinogen the
amount that's a lot is ten times higher
ten times higher than a can of lead
paint is what's in this product consumer
groups including the Environmental
Defense Fund are now asking the FDA to
get the lead acetate out EDF Tom Milner
we want FDA to remove its approval for
lead acetate as a color additive and
hair dyes in other words you can't use
this in these products right so find a
safer alternative do not use to color
mustache beard eyelashes manufacturers
of the products tell consumers to only
use the dye on their hair but then it
all follow
directions this 2014 study documents the
case of one man who used progressive
hair dye with lead acetate to color his
beard and had numbness and tingling in
both feet and hands for seven months
study author dr. Wissam D he was very
surprised that there was lead in his
product and did he stopped the product
the moment he discovered that there was
lead in it but lead acetate is a much
bigger concern for children government
health authorities warned to not allow
children to touch hair colored with lead
containing dyes because the compounds
can rub off onto their hands and be
transferred to their mouths when you use
it in the real world it's going to be
led on the soap dispenser lead on the
faucet led on the counter and kids will
get exposed to it that way the company
that owns Grecian formula comb declined
an on-camera interview but told us in a
statement that the data on hand to mouth
transmission of lead is insufficient and
that lead acetate has been used safely
as a color additive in progressive hair
dye products for decades based on
extensive scientific studies now to be
clear the FDA does currently approve the
use of lead acetate in these products we
also reached out to American Industries
International the manufacturer of youth
hair products but did not receive a
response by newstime youth hair does
offer a lead-free alternative product
here in the United States but again the
main concern is for kids yeah I say
thank you Jesus for hair color but you
don't want anybody to get hurt doing it
right exactly
you understand yeah yeah well women
everywhere understand that's all thank
you so I don't want to bother Jesus with
this yes yes that's a good attitude I
thank you all